I don't understand it's really not that
special he did
he gets confused about all that
all that not true
Charlemagne the guy
no five one FM's Breakfast Club where he
was asked about the rumors surrounding
his
um
you know it's a very normal
size penis it's like you know not too
big or too small it's just like you know
yeah I don't understand that P
itch joy and not big enough for it to
hurt okay this is what I was told
alludes to it in the new trailer for his
peacock series budget he's not that big
right like Thanos
Pete first got the bde label thanks to
his ex-fiance Ariana Grande who
commented on Pete's
um nether region when asked how long her
song Pete Davidson was Ari joked it's 10
inches it was like so crazy Pete popped
the question to the singer in 2018 but
they called it quits later that year
then in 2019 Ariana famously gave him a
post-split shout out in her track thank
you next
yeah that's a pick of Ari and Pete with
the words huge scribbled on the page and
Pete addressed the compliment during his
stand-up show she did that so that every
girl that sees my for the rest of my
life is disappointed
[Music]
since Ariana Pete's been linked to
several other high-profile celebs like
Kate Beckinsale Margaret quali Kaia
Gerber Phoebe Denver and of course Kim
Kardashian he's just super genuine
Pete even had Kim's famous family's seal
of approval I love that he's kind and
really really thoughtful he's the most
thoughtful person and I love yeah and I
love the chemistry that Kim and him have
together it's really sweet that's just
she said chemistry I'm just like okay
chemistry
but that chemistry fizzled out after
nine months together they split last
year and he moved on with Emily
radakowski for a hot SEC he seems super
Charming he's vulnerable he's lovely now
he's dating his bodies bodies bodies
co-star Chase sui wonders oh what is she
doing here the two have been linked for
several months and back in January A
source told ET they like each other a
lot they'll share the screen again in
Pete's upcoming peacock series bubkiss
you run away from people who love you I
don't do that but the series which is
Loosely based on the comedian's life
will Chronicle more than just his love
life it's my anniversary can I borrow
your catch Pete in all his bde glory
when it debuts May 4th
foreign